COVID-19 PROTOCOL.
NINE GAMES MISSED THIS SEASON
FOR LARS IN PROTOCOL.
HE MISSED IND TWO OF HIS
BUDDIES OUTSIDE.
>> HE THOUGHGH Joe: 31-YEAR-OL
KEMPNY HAS IT FOR WASHINGTON.
KEMPNY IN THTHAT IS NOW 11 POIN
GAMES FOR RADULOV AGAINS
SHEARY TURNS THE CORNER.
PICKED UP BELOW THE GOAL LINE
BY HANLEY.S THE EARLY LEAD.
THERE IS A QUALITY OPPORTUNITY.
>> Craig: IF YOU CHANCESTOUCH O
BEFORE OETTINGER GOT
COMING UP THE WALL.
THE EASTERN CONFERENCE.  TO GE
YOU SEE HOW TIGHT .
FAKS
ZONE.
A COUPLE OF GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES.
THEY HAD THE PUCK THREE
DIFFERENT TIMES AND OCKED HOLTBT
UP.
IT IS ROOPE  DAY AND AGE.
HERE IS SEGUIN.
PAVELSKI.
GETSGAME.
HE PLAYS THE WALL AS WELL T INTG
WHEN YOU MISHANDLED THE PUCK ,
YOU ARE OFTEN ED IT INTO HIS GL.
THIS WILL THE CAPS BACK TO
RIPS IT THROUGH THE DEFENSEMAN.
HAKANPAA. D 10 IN THE STANLEY C
SEASON OF '17-'18.
IT IS E FLEX OF THE
LEG.
I THINK K
IN HIS LAST 13 GAMES OVERALL.
SKINS IT
CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
HERE IS THE  REELING
BIG-TIME.
THE CAPS HAVE 54.8